[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with columnist
carol malone and broadcaster steve
richards they'll be with us from now
right up until just before midnight
so let's see now what's on some of those
front pages for you
human rights pariah is the headline in
the metro after the united nations voted
to strip russia of its place on the un
human rights council over its invasion
of ukraine
while the financial times reports that a
russian aluminium company has become the
first group within the country to call
for an inquiry into alleged war crimes
in the ukrainian town of butcher
the tax affairs of the wife of
chancellor rishi sunak our lead story in
the telegraph with allies of the sunnex
claiming that number 10 is trying to
undermine him
the time says the chancellor is worried
that revelations about his wife's
non-domicile tax status are a hit job
that story is also lead in the guardian
which says she may have avoided up to 20
million pounds in uk tax
but the son has an interview with the
chancellor in which he says
lay off my misses
the male leads with the health secretary
sergey javid calling for the nhs to
protect women-only hospital wards as
access for trans women to female only
wards is under
review the style reports that shoppers
are panic buying a certain flavor of
walker's crisp before the recipe is
changed the headline
pack it in
reminder that by scanning the qr code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
well tonight we're joined by columbus
carl malone and broadcaster steve
richards uh welcome to you both let's um
start with the
metro and the headline there human
rights pariah and this in reference to
russia being uh losing its its seat on
the un human rights council
carol
okay sorry
uh yeah it's it's it's been suspended
from the council if you just said um for
gross violations of human rights this is
a very unusual happening it's only
happened once before libya was suspended
in 2011
um
after violence against protesters by
qadhafi's forces so this is this is
quite a big thing um the motion was 93
countries voted in favor of suspending
him
um
24 against and 58 abstains but the
abstentions don't count so what it meant
was that they needed a two-thirds
majority to do it and so it's been done
but you know i'm not sure how much
putin cares about that we call him a
global pariah you know that's not the
narrative that'll be being peddled in
russia uh and you know and and the thing
is he still controls the narrative in
russia he no longer is able to peddle
his lies around the rest of the world
but in russia
he does and so i'm not quite sure how
how you know how difficult this is going
to be for him whether it's going to make
any difference to him at all um but you
know and and we you know we've been
talking about um the atrocities today
and and and
you know we now know that there are he
still you know you guys have an
interview today with with petrov one of
his spokespersons in the kreml kremlin
who was who was saying who was denying
all claims of atrocities everywhere but
now we know that is not the case um and
we now have proof we have russians
talking about what they have done and
what they're going to do with ukrainian
prisoners of war so you know if this is
this is difficult for putin it's like
you know your guy petrov today said
there was no chance that he'd ever be
brought before a war crimes tribunal um
maybe maybe that's what they believe but
the thing is now we have evidence for
that but i don't think that much bothers
him either frankly yeah so that was an
extraordinary interview with demetria
peskov to today um steve i just wonder
what difference do you think it will
make russia losing their seat on the un
human rights council
what difference does it make in the
context of this nightmare in ukraine
none at all it seems to me i mean every
twist and turn some dark some you think
yeah it's good that the un have done
this
uh i always pose the question does this
lead any more clearly towards what form
the end of this nightmare will take and
it seems to me this is an example of
something that doesn't as carol suggests
putin can control the way this will be
presented in russia if it's presented at
all and it will be presented as oh these
damn countries always against russia and
so on
um so i suspect it will have no
practical
difference in terms of
standing within russia
and it's it's hard to read we're coming
to a story which suggests there are some
internal criticisms surfacing from
within russia which may prove to be more
significant frankly than this uh action
from the u.n
yes and we know that the vote was uh 93
to 24. and carol one wonders about the
the 24 um and what the the the future
holds for
them yeah i mean north korea was one of
those who voted against and i haven't
looked to see if i can find the rest and
i can't but some of the abstentions were
brazil india and pakistan
um you know they're strategically there
they're just not doing it but it is
interesting where what yeah i mean north
korea you would expect um
from one dictator to another you'd
expect that to happen um but yes i mean
i wonder if we will find out who the
others are the um and also the the 58
abstentions i mean you know who were
they apart from the three i've just
mentioned for goodness sake yeah no that
that's an interesting point don't you
think steve
yeah although throughout this the there
has not been i mean uh with some
internal tensions which i think will
become greater as this goes on you know
there has been unity on the whole from
the west from the united states the eu
the uk and so on um but that hasn't been
universal
and that's reflected in in those who
didn't vote for this
let's move to the financial times and uh
rousseau the aluminium producers become
the first russian company to call for a
public inquiry that's into the alleged
war crimes in butcher carroll
yeah the dutch chairman of this company
has called for that
steven this is steve knows more about
this me but you know basically we don't
know what's happening in russia we don't
know what people think in russia we've
we see what we see in the papers every
day but we don't know the truth but here
we have one company one aluminium maker
calling for a public inquiry and saying
that you know if it if it is found that
that russia has been um you know has
been committing these atrocities in bush
and various other cities that the the
people to russia has to be severely
punished and it's it's a brave move
actually you just wonder whether how
many more companies might come out and
follow this hopefully they will because
that will make life very difficult for
putin um
it's a brave man he's a this guy is a
brave guy to to do it but you know how
many more will yeah rousseau's the
world's biggest aluminium producer
outside china and steve just how
significant is it for a russian company
to come out and call for uh an inquiry
regarding butcher
i think it is quite significant as you
say they're a very big company in russia
and it tells us two things one that
there is talk within certain sectors of
russian uh community
about war crimes there is not just a a
blanket acceptance that these things are
not even
worth exploring and the second thing is
this company is calling for an
investigation it is really worth
exploring in terms of them now it's very
hard to read and i have no clue the
degree of real support for putin within
russia i assume but don't know it's
still high
but when you get this kind of quite
powerful voice because you know the
russian economy is under all kinds of
pressures
um so when you get a voice like this
saying right we need an investigation
into alleged war crimes i think that is
much trickier for putin to handle than
uh what happened in the u.n today yeah
interesting point about those people in
russia that's not knowing what they're
seeing carol i was speaking to someone a
russian
person that i met recently who was
saying that her family was divided that
her mother
was extremely angry with her for not
supporting the war in in russia um and
they're simply not seeing the evidence
that that we are and they don't have the
detail
that it seems to be the case julie that
the older generation you know the people
who remember mother russia as it was
those people are supporters of putin and
will be till the day that they die i
think the the revolution is being led by
younger people would seem very sick we
saw the the the guy this week the artist
who lay down um in in a moscow street
with his hands tied behind his back
a very brave thing to do but he was he
was kind of you know making the point
that this is what's happening in ukraine
uh and so i think there are breaker i
think the young people particularly are
going to be um you know are going to be
doing this they're the people who
we have to hope for um but you know but
i think you know it's interesting you
talk about we talk about the economy you
know i read something today that said
the economy is going to be set back 15
years by the sanctions that are
currently in place just imagine how much
damage we could do if we got even
tougher sanctions in place and you know
the stumbling block to that at the
moment is germany uh they you know they
don't want other sanctions because
they're still buying you know those
incredible figures today out of europe
that europe is is spending 35 has spent
35 billion quid sent it to russia for
oil and gas since this war started so so
much for sanctions and and actually in
in contrast to that
you europe has only sent one billion in
military aid now that sounds like a lot
but it's not a lot compared to the 35
billion that they're spending on oil and
gas and and that is shocking and
shameful and you know
ukraine are calling again tonight
they're actually saying to to nato you
know we only have one simple request and
it's three words it's weapons weapons
and more weapons and that's what we have
to do
about sanctions a i suspect of the uk
was as dependent on russian gas as
germany is um it too would be pretty
reluctant to switch that off and face
the immediate economic consequences and
i would add just another word question
about sanctions yes it's hitting russia
and will continue to do so
but soon it's gonna especially if we
don't as i'm obsessed with how this is
going to end one option is a sort of
terrible war of attrition going on for a
long long time
we haven't fully tested yet the
willingness of people here germany
france the whole of europe america of
the impact and the consequences of
sanctions here which are beginning to be
felt it's one of the drivers of
inflation um but it will get much worse
if the sanctions we impose uh continue
so that's that's another sort of
uh
wild card in all of this how much
economic pain
the west is willing to take
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me columnist carol
malone and broadcaster steve richards
welcome back to both of you let's go
straight
to the telegraph and uh rishi sunak his
uh woes continue but he's claiming that
uh he's being undermined by number 10
this is in the story regarding his
wife's tax affairs carol
i mean i think it's spot on you know as
soon as i as soon as i read started to
read the stuff yesterday
you know on the day the national
insurance rates came into into effect we
start hearing all these stories about
mrs sunak's non-dom status this is not a
new story you know people in government
will have known of her status for a long
time and it's just interesting it start
it comes out on the day the the ni rates
came you came into effect you know it's
you know boris said today um you know
you know what does it say keep families
out of it and i heard that and thought
well that doesn't sound right to me
either you know especially when sunax
allies are saying all this briefing is
coming out of number 10. and i
completely believe that it is you know
rishi sunak you know one of his allies
said today is the only credible show in
town and i think that's true and and
he's he's always been a threat to boris
a few months ago he was looking very
much like he could possibly be the next
prime minister of partygate having gone
boris's way
um and and i and i i do feel that people
are trying to undermine him and you know
i i find it astonishing that that in
this 21st century we live in people seem
to imagine that rishi sunek should take
charge of his wife's tax affairs he
should tell her she has to do them in a
certain way we should make it clear that
mrs sunak has done nothing wrong the
non-dawn policy has been around for a
very long time you know ed miliband was
moaning about it today well labor never
changed the non-dom policy and they have
no intention of doing so so i find this
this really and and to be having a go it
is why especially ed miliband had to go
and you know this is the man who a few
years ago uh when there were there were
very stories about his um marxist
academic father
when berserker was saying this is
personal you can't do this and you're
besmirching my father's name there's not
an awful lot of difference with what ed
mal in minnebound is doing now to mr
sumac and i just i just think it's it's
it's a bit rich for people to imagine
that rishi should have put his foot down
and said to his wife this is what you
have to do
but but i do concede that none of this
looks good in a cost of living crisis
when sunak and his wife who are worth
well she's she's the daughter of a
billionaire he's worth millions in his
own right it does not look good at a
time when um you know when people are
struggling to make ends meet when
they're terrified whether they can
switch the lights on let's just bring
let's just
let's just bring out stephen just
wondering if you agree with uh carol
that that the chancellor is being
deliberately undermined and this perhaps
has scuppered his chances his ambitions
to to one day be prime minister
i think this is a very big story and if
it wasn't for the hell of ukraine would
be even bigger for two reasons one um if
it is true as the telegraph suggests and
other papers too that number 10 are
briefly against sunak it utterly
kind of implicitly damning ways
this bodes ill for
the government in the next few months
because we all know what happens when
there are tensions between prime
ministers and chancellors it's deeply
destabilizing
but to be destabilized in the context of
the cost of living crisis inflation and
all the rest of it um makes it even more
significant as a story but the other
thing is i think that rishi sunak
if if you don't mind me saying i did a
book recently on the prime ministers we
never had one thing that struck me was
nearly all chancellors who were seen as
next prime minister never got the crown
in most cases
and and i've always thought sunak was
not going to seize the crown because
when you start doing unpopular things as
a chancellor
your personal ratings fall now if you
throw in his vast wealth and all the
rest of the stuff that's coming out
about the non-dom states of his wife
um i think he's in a really tricky
position having been the clear favorite
to succeed just a few weeks ago